You know the saying behind every great man is a great woman. Well,
it also applies to men who are the exact opposite of great.
Jen Ching was the fourth wife of chairman Mao Zedong,
the man who oversaw one of history's deadliest Brigham's,
but rather than merely supporting her husband,
Jang was an active participant in his atrocities as a key member of the cultural
revolution group.
She dragged China into a decade of chaos that kills up to 2 million people.
She pursued spiteful, vendettas,
ordering the murders of people who had snubbed her decades.
Before I said 1980 trial, she famously described herself as a mouse attack,
dog declaring whomever. He said to bite. I bet,
but while Jen Ching ended her life a revolutionary psychopath,
she certainly didn't start it that way. There's a young woman.
Jang had been a movie starlet.
She had had affairs appeared in tabloids and engaged in behaviors.
So scandalous, the communist party wanted nothing to do with her yet.
Somehow she Rose to the top of that same party ushering in an era of
unparalleled chaos. Join us as we explore the life of Jen Ching,
the architect of the cultural revolution,
Just the slightest tweaking gen Ching story could have been a Hollywood
fairytale born in March, 1914. The girl grew up in heartbreaking poverty.
Her mother was a concubine and her father a landowning drunk.
You seem to be competing for the title. Most toxic purveyor of masculinity.
He beads both women so frequently that the girl eventually snaps into age just
14. She ran away from home.
It would be thanks to this escape that the girl discovered her true love acting
incidentally,
the girl wasn't called Chan chin yet over her life should go by many names and
it's just by luck. This Jen Ching eventually stuck before she became Jang.
Though, the girl would live a very different life.
After a year with an acting troupe.
The girls signed up with a brand new experimental arts Academy in Shang dong,
graduating in 1933. She headed straight for Shanghai.
It was almost the perfect time to be a 19 year old actress in East Asia's
Hollywood. Just a couple of years earlier,
the nationalist Cuming Tang and the Chenko shattered reunited China after nearly
two decades of warlord chaos.
Now with China in the throws of the Nanjing decades,
peace and prosperity artificially resends well, they had, for some people,
at least Shanghai in 1933 was deeply unequal. The rich were rich.
The poor were destitute and left wing radicalism suffused the app.
Although the girl noticed at first,
she was too focused on living out our Shanghai dreams.
Although Jangs early years in the city was spends in minor ranks in groups.
She was still beautiful and hedonistic enough to party with the rich and famous.
She drank like a fish,
got herself swept up in scandals and chased her big break.
She even was jailed for three months. So having one States to communist,
but what did it matter? Really? This was all just part of a story.
The tale of how one girl from a miserable backgrounds,
Rose to become China's greatest stop.
And Jangs star really was rising in 1934.
She translated a breakout role than a Henrik Ibsen play into a contract to
produce films with a left wing company.
She changed an interland ping or blue Apple and prepared to embark on her
fairytale,
but already the cold wind of reality was beginning to seep in that same year,
the communists 46,000 kilometer retreat from combing Tang forces known as the
long March, both the parties,
foundational myth and the events that made now it's undisputed leader.
It was the first sign of the radical change that would soon sweep China,
even blue Apple noticed then Shanghai.
She began appearing in socially conscious films come 1936.
Jan was reveling in both our growing roles and to tabloid already in love life.
She had a melodramatic affair with a critic.
This ended with him trying to kill himself, not once,
but twice a first proper celebrity scandal,
but the trouble with fairytales even gaudy ones is that they're not real.
Jan Ching may have been living a rags to riches story.
But it was exactly that a story one that would.
Improve as fake as the stagey love scenes that she acted in.
This was China in the 20th century. Remember nobody,
least of all Jan Ching was going to have a happy ending
Parity of the Nanjing decade. Abruptly ended on July the seventh, 1937.
That was the day a skirmish between Japanese and Chinese troops at the Marco
polo bridge snowballed into a full blown Japanese invasion as the second
Sino-Japanese war erupted.
Jen floods exposed Shanghai for the wartime capital of Chong Ching good
job too. Only a month after the Marco polo bridge incidents,
the Japanese marched on the port city unleashing an orgy of islands. Yeah,
this wouldn't be the only city Jen Ching flood that year and nationalists John
Jen,
she became worried her socially conscious left-wing films would come back to
haunt up. So she fled again, this time crossing into communist territory.
And that was how she wound up meeting the man who transformed Chinese history by
1937 miles dong was in his mid forties and security in control of the communist
movements.
He was also showing classic signs of dictator egomania when he spoke at your non
arts Academy, he couldn't help,
but be flattered by the audience member with the movie stolen looks the one who
enthusiastically applauded his,
every word that meeting after mouse speech was the start of GM King's real
rise.
Not that it would be easy or even particularly moral at the time Jang and mal
became lovers. Now we're still married to his third wife.
He's a gen loyal revolutionary.
Who'd been one of the few women to survive the long March.
So she was so popular within the communist movements that the party tried to
stop mousy and Jang, but now was petulance declaring without a blue Apple.
I cannot go on with the revolution and long last,
and only when Jan was pregnant,
it was an agreement reached now could marry the actress,
but you have to promise that she would never try to enter politics.
This was a big deal. The wives of most communist leaders had very public,
very powerful roles within the party. Not quite equal to their husbands,
but not exactly stuck at home,
but it seems the communist higher ups could sense.
Jangs burning ambition hung off of power. That was almost equal to mouse.
So they made mal promise and unexpectedly now kept that promise.
He divorced his yen and had a committed to a Russian mental hospital.
Then married Jang and proceeded to push her back into the shadows in no time at
all of the sex had gone from their relationship.
Mal began shacking up with young revolutionaries behind Yang's back.
Although he never divorced, she was too loyal to fawning, never answering back,
worshiping him like a God. So Mao capita, even as the Japanese were defeated,
even as he turned on and destroyed the Komen Tang and became head of the
people's Republic of China in October, 1949, but little did Mauser.
Don realize that his demure is a wife was using him as ruthlessly as he used
others. Sex is engaging in the first rounds,
Jen Ching later set of their relationship.
But what sustains interest in the long run is power by her relationship
with Mouser dong should soon amass enough power to transform the face of China.
For real,
With rulings and full narratives is that life is rarely that simple rather than
shooting to the top.
And most people just stumble upwards and then stumbled back down.
Such was the case with Jan chin.
At least for the rise part kept in the backgrounds by Mao and heavily medicated.
It's likely Jang in the 1950s didn't feel she was rising at all.
Instead it seems she mostly felt mentally unwell.
She began to believe the colors pink and Brown triggered migraines that even the
quietest house was filled with inescapable noise snobbery by leading communists,
she belittled and shouted at everyone who came near her yet refuse to be left
alone for even a minute. For those familiar with mouse pass marriage,
it must've seemed like Jen Ching was doomed to be shipped off to, uh,
own Russian asylum in the very near future.
But before you go feeling too sorry for her,
we should probably take a quick look at what was happening in the rest of China
at the end of the 1950s.
Mao's great leap forward triggered probably the worst famine in human history as
villages were corralled into communes and forced to meet impossible grain
quotas, their story, and a Frank Decata estimates,
45 million staff to death for a grim comparison points.
The total number of dead in the whole of world war one was around 20 million.
So yeah,
it probably kind of socks is a Madame Mao locked away in snubbed by your
husband's comrades,
but it probably sucked significantly more to be dying in some frozen field. Yes,
it would be the same famine that rescued gin gin from a scarcity by
1962.
It was obvious to even now that is great leap forward had been more like the
great leap into a catastrophe.
The atmosphere in the party was mucinous.
There were open criticisms of now suddenly weakens the Chapman needed as many
ultra loyalists around us that you could find less TV to post and who was more
loyal than his darling wife on September the 29th, 1962,
over 20 years after they married Mao introduced Jen Ching to a party
conference, bringing her into the limelight immediately.
Jang began amassing a power base latching onto the defense minister in PR.
She had made herself the Army's cultural commissar from the ashy engineered a
drive to purify China's culture,
purging playwrights and opera companies that failed to produce appropriately.
Revolutionary works at the height of her purge,
even managed to top all the minister of culture,
big scalp for someone so new to the game. But then again,
Jen Ching was a natural death spots ever since an actress days,
she had excelled at holding a grudge,
and now we're given a free reign to attack the cultural sex. Uh,
she had said about harassing as many detractors as she could get away with.
She'd even stuck. The knife into a husband is one of the revolutionary plays.
She approved involved in elderly Tyron's with a beautiful young wife.
He fails to satisfy and then kills now with heroin.
He watched the Beijing performance looking like someone had just forced fed in
the sink full of lemons, but rather than turn on his newly insolent wife,
Jangs spirited purge seems to have given now a bit of an idea by
1965,
there were dangerous rumblings that the failure of the great leap forward could
topple the chairman.
So bowel survive the only way he knew how not by setting traps and reflexively
purging like Starlin would, but by creating so much chaos,
his rule would come to be seen as the one steady rock that the nation could
cling to. He called his new project, the cultural revolution,
and it would send China spiraling into new depths of maps.
[Inaudible].
February, 1965.
Jan chin found herself rezoning to Shanghai on Mao's orders for the first time
in years. Although you should needle him with a play.
Jan was always fanatically loyal to her husband when he's older to go back to
the city of our acting days, she didn't think twice. Once in Shanghai,
Jan hooked up with the party's local director of propaganda [inaudible] and to
the acerbic writer, Yahweh and Yon together,
they would form three quarters of China's notorious gang of four,
but that was in the future for now.
The gang of not quite four were focused on setting up a secret rival to
Beijing's ministry of culture just in time for mal to purge the real thing now
had already chosen the cultural sphere as the next battle grounds.
He just needed someone to first clear the decks of the party's old guard,
Jan Ching happily obliged in February, 1966,
our Shanghai unit launched a broadside against the last guardians of culture.
Labeling them a black force, trying to dominate our politics right onto you.
The targets were denounced and purged leaving the Shanghai units at the
forefronts of propaganda.
It was the start of a steady drum beat towards Xanarchy.
The pace first picked up in when the people's daily, a party mouthpiece,
exhorted students to turn against cultural traders against speed.
When students in the cities responded by painting the first big character
posters, sheets,
as big as a door sprayed with revolutionary calls to arms and denunciations.
Finally,
it reached a Gallop when mal made his move on may the 16th malware organized a
secret memo, targeting bourgeoisie who had sneaked into the communist party,
the government, the army, and various spheres of culture. Shortly thereafter,
the cultural revolution group was born consisting of Jen Ching and a gang of
four minus one. Plus some ultra loyalists.
The group was allowed to operate outside of checks and balances from their
offices near the forbidden city. They controlled propaganda.
The means of communication, the machinery of state.
It was essentially a coup one, which kept now in charge,
but rips power away from anyone unto him,
who wasn't named Jang Ching and Madame Mao was determined to use a new found
power to make our husband proud. You have an [inaudible] came on June.
The first that day,
the cultural revolution group issued an article in the people's daily.
Calling on students do sweep away all monsters and demons.
It's singled out teachers and school masters claiming they corrupted the youth
with reactionary thoughts that same evening,
big character posters put up by Beijing students denouncing that teachers will
read out live on radio. The next day, all schools were suspended.
There's the opening of the floodgates rather than stay home.
The nation's teenagers swarmed to their schools where party cadres handed out
paper and paint.
Big character posters began appearing in every classroom by breeding teachers
and fellow students.
But what to do with those who had been to now inst the answer came on June the
13th. That day I to televise mass draw in Beijing images were broadcast of
counter-revolutionaries forced to confess their sins and submit before a
screaming crowd of thousands. Even girls, as young as six were filmed,
shrieking kill,
kill the template for the cultural revolution had at last been
set. Now is the time for the carnage to begin.
[Inaudible].
1966, China slips into a hellish fever dream across the June and July.
The nation students went full Lord of the flies.
Denounced teachers were forced to wear Dunn,
scaps or made to crawl through school with signs saying dog hanging around.
Then next by the middle of the month, the students have graduated to torture,
forcing principals to kneel on broken glass for hours at a time on June the 16th
chairman Mao's swam across the Yangtze river to show he was ready for
ideological battle.
He dismantled the work team's future premier den shopping that sent him to
schools to try and calm the situation by late July.
The first deaths from suicide from overzealous torture had been reported,
but mal responded simply by painting his own big character poster declaring
bombards the headquarters shortly after a big character posters swept out of
schools and across Beijing covering every available surface.
It became vital to study them every day to see if you'd been denounced.
But the real terror started on August the eighth, that day,
just three days after a gang of teenage girls and publicly beaten their
vice-principal to death.
The cultural revolution group announced 16 new articles.
The articles encouraged students to destroy the full olds, old customs,
old culture, old habits and old ideas. And most importantly,
they declared that no action would be taken against students who engaged in
violence.
No matter what they did just like that open season had been
declared red August is infamous today.
How quickly it devolved into anarchy teenagers. Most of them barely 14 or 15.
Self-organized into red guard units that imprisoned teachers and fellow students
and killed them in grotesque ways. People had boiling water poured over them.
Others were stoned to death in elementary schools,
children of only 10 or 12 forced their teachers to swallow nails. Soon,
the violence was spilling out into the streets.
As teenage red guards began attacking the homes of anyone who looked
counterrevolutionary not long after lists of targets for bad by the cultural
revolution group started appearing on walls,
adding to the violence by late September,
nearly 2000 people had been murdered in Beijing alone butts for gen Ching life
was a non-stop party as now used the chaos to shore up his own position.
Jang used it to settle scores in January of 1967.
Her group over through the local communist party in Shanghai triggering a wave
of uprisings.
His red guards seized weapons from the army and turn cities into war zones at
blast United with the last member of her gang of four,
the labor activist Wang Hong, when Jang became the face of the chaos,
gripping China, she had head on posters, made speeches to tens of thousands.
Had books dedicated to her in charge of culture and outfit.
She banned all the eight operas and wrote exacting rules on how everything from
music to theater to novels should be created.
She then said about using these rules to target all of those.
She felt had personally wronged our actor, ciao. Dan,
who refused to appear opposite her onstage in the 1930s was hounded and
tortured.
A script writer named Shand yang was denounced because he hadn't wanted to write
Jang apart decades before a CoStar named Lee Lily,
who'd gotten better reviews for a 1936 film. She in Jang appeared in,
was arrested.
The whole family tortured husband died from the ordeal nor did Jang stop at
artists.
The children of senior communists suet snubbed her after a marriage to malware
murders. The future premiere dang shopping was denounced twice.
And his son crippled by torture even today's Chinese president Xi Jing things,
or his father arrested and humiliated during the upheaval,
the Westport Jang Chen and the cultural revolution group.
We're just getting started
In 1967 Malraux to Jang Chang telling her the goal of the revolution
was a great disorder under heaven that would later inspire greater order under
heaven. The Germans certainly got the firmest part, right?
A full accounts of all the crimes committed would probably require a starting a
whole new channel called revolution to graphics and uploading daily videos.
For the next five years boss,
we can give you an overview so you can understand how it must've felt to be
alive. At that time.
The biggest flavor of the period was a mix of insanity and extreme cruelty
in Beijing red guard units, declared cats with symbols of bourgeoisie,
decadence,
and set about conducting a great cast massacre in which thousands of strays are
tortured and killed out in the villages of Volkswagen,
human bad elements were vivisected alive.
Their internal organs eaten by local party bosses in Dow's Yan villages use the
chaos to settle old scores,
butchering the babies of enemies for having a bad class backgrounds.
Often this chaos was utterly self-defeating in Wu Han.
So many doctors were denounced that the healthcare system collapsed in Shang Xi.
The transport networks fell apart.
So spectacularly that feminine set in millions were reduced to two eating mud
and bark to survive.
Then there were the suicides being denounced in the cultural revolution didn't
always mean being killed, but it did mean losing your job,
being paraded through the streets,
spat on by your neighbors and humiliated in front of thousands and struggle
sessions.
Not surprisingly many killed themselves in the wake of this and who Bay 600
people committed suicide in just six weeks. Overall.
It's thought that anywhere between 500,000 and 2 million died in the cultural
revolution with millions more tortured by self appointed,
teenage revolutionaries by attend the education system have disintegrated.
20% of the population was suffering from malnutrition productivity had
collapsed. The economy was a ruin,
but it achieved its goal now's it was still in power and stronger than ever.
Sadly for Jen Ching though, her survival wasn't so clear. Cut in 1968,
mal began to worry that his wife was getting too powerful.
He started telling people she had great aspirations, but not an ounce of talent.
Shortly after the military moved into the cities to restore order or ed guns
were disarmed and sent by the millions to the countryside to learn from the
peasants. In reality,
this meant 12 million teenagers essentially becoming slaves forced to do
backbreaking labor, thousands of kilometers from home. Yeah,
it's a Lockwood ensure that Jen Ching wasn't thrown to the wolves alongside them
as the anarchic phase of the cultural revolution wound down there.
Now aging mal anointed, the general Lin Biao as his heir apparent,
but when then was killed in a plane crash,
it was Jen chin and a gang of four that filled the vacuum still completely in
control of culture and propaganda.
Jang was now on a crazy high with no one left to replace.
Now it really looks like she might become China's next leader by 1974,
she was even comparing herself to the legendary Uzi tan.
The only Empress did directly rule Imperial China, sadly for blue Apple though.
Fate had other plans rather than being the thing that ensured our survival.
The cultural revolution would ensure gen chings downfall.
In the end.
Jang Chang was outplayed by one dang shopping,
purged and rehabilitated under Mao,
and then purge twice by the car revolution group. Dang,
finally reappeared in public life in 1975 by now,
Jan was basically waiting for two powerful old men to die.
Her husbands and the popular premiere ciao and lie.
When Joe obligingly kicked to the buckets on January the eighth, 1976,
Jenn swiftly purged his allies ridding herself of the last challenges to a
power.
She forbid public mourning of jail wins when den shopping made a stirring speech
in the premiere has memory. She had been purged for the 9000000th time,
but crafty dang had realized something that Madame Mao was too arrogant to
see the gang of four were hated by the military and the party,
their power lay and their ability to whip up the mall.
But to get the people on their side, the same people who had loved premier Zhao,
the same premier Zhao,
whose memory Jang had just pistol over by arresting dang for
honoring him on March 31st, 1976,
protesters appeared in gentleman's square crying, Jang, the witch,
as she watched through binoculars blue Apple had them attacked and beaten with
on boss lay scaffold into them, right? But the damage had been done.
Jang had now attacked both the people's premiere, right?
The people themselves never again with the gang of four,
be able to unleash anarchy on the streets. And one fell swoop.
Jang had destroyed one of the two things, keeping her alive.
The other vanish shortly thereafter on September the ninth,
1976 miles long died at the age of 18,
less than a month later was a BRM using was called they're.
The three isn't members of the gang of four were arrested paranoid to the end.
John Chang had wisely stayed away,
but she was quickly tracked down and arrested by military who are now looking
for revenge as if to underscore how low opinion of the gang of four fallen news
of their downfall caused such big celebrations that Beijing ran out of
alcohol four years later with Dennis sharping. Now not just rehabilitated,
but in charge of the country,
that trial began things problem was that someone needed to do draw the line
under the accesses of the Mao era is Khrushchev had done with stolen in his
secret speech,
but now was both the parties stolen and it's Lennon and it's source of
legitimacy for ruling China mountains.
The whole edifice would come crashing down. Dang.
His response was masterful while admitting Mao had made mistakes.
The formula had landed on was that 70% of the stuff the chairman did was good
and 30% was bad doing this.
Dang shifted nearly all the blame for the many atrocities onto blue Apple at a
show trial,
Jang was blamed for the entire cultural revolution while she fought back telling
the assembled communists, if I am guilty,
how about you will it wasn't called a show trial for nothing in early 1981,
Jan Ching was sentenced to death, commuted to life in prison.
She was dragged from the court screaming, traitors fascists,
but at the time was over a decade later in may of 1991,
Jang was reported to have hung herself in a cell.
Supposedly she left a note declaring chairman. I love you.
Your students and comrade is coming to see you today.
Jen chings name remains mud in China while dang shopping is hailed as the man
who saved the economy and her husband is still lionized as a great leader,
just like the whole 30% thing.
Jang is associated only with the nightmare of the cultural revolution.
Certainly she deserves this.
Jang was a monster vindictive sociopath who helped engineer the
chaos that killed maybe 2 million people.
And yet it's worth remembering that she wasn't acting alone without Mao's
desperate need to cling to power.
The cultural revolution could have never happened no matter how vicious Jang
was. Madame Mau was the architect of a catastrophe. Yes,
but it was all in service of her.
Husband's a man modern China still efficiently deifies even while they're
missing. He made mistakes in the end.
Jang may not have got a fairytale ending.
That's a thuggish husbands got something like it. At least.
Whereas reputation was concerned sadly in her death that was in her life.
It seems that the troubled young actress was only ever destined to play a
supporting role. So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below and don't forget to subscribe.
Thank you for watching.